ESG what is ESG just last week Zero
Hedge did a story I'm sure you saw this
the ESG rules continues
pager 10. Legacy tobacco companies are
posting higher ESG scores than EV maker
Tesla
here we go all right tobacco companies
such as can you pull up the Tweet please
rob put tobacco companies such as Philip
Morris and British American Tobacco have
received higher ESG scores than Tesla
with Philip Morris scoring 84 points and
British American Tobacco score 94 while
Tesla only scored 37 okay
tobacco companies have stret
strategically embraced corporate
progress progress progressivism focused
on diversity initiatives and social
justice causes while Tesla has been less
engaged in these areas tobacco companies
are gaming the system by embracing
corporate progress progressivism notes
the report Tesla report Tesla's lower
ESG score could make it vulnerable to
socially conscious activist investors
seeking board seats for Co removal Elon
Musk expressed frustration questioning
whether Tesla would face pressure from
virtue signaling investors like those
who targeted Exxon I posted this tweet
and I said so cigarettes do more good
for climate than a Tesla the hypocrisy
of ESG scores to Tesla gets 37 out of
100 Philip Morris 84. who's supposed to
believe this nonsense musk responded to
this actually if you get lower and he
said exactly but I mean this is a guy
that's actually helping the climate and
the other guys are not and they're
getting a better what are your thoughts
about the story well this is why I said
this whole world view is anti-merit
right because it doesn't reward people
who are doing stuff it rewards people
who are signaling right like you you
take this box you've got this many
people from this demographic working at
your company that means you're better
even if you're selling people cigarettes
right and it and it creates a world of
perverse incentives and as you know
Patrick the people respond to incentives
if you put the wrong incentives in place
people are going to do the wrong things
well you ask the initial question the
ESG because on the surface it seems
ridiculous so if you look at it at the
the E the S the G there's basically
three different uh obviously prototypes
here so e stands for environmental waste
and pollution this is how they basically
score you if you want to learn the score
goes waste and pollution resource
depletion greenhouse gas emission
deforestation and climate change so
that's the environmental right social
employee relations and diversity there's
your Dei stuff right there working
conditions local communities health and
safety and a conflict governance tax
strategy executive remuneration
donations and political lobbying
corruption and bribery board diversity
and structure so it's one of those
things where you could on the surface
score very high probably on the
environmental but maybe you don't do so
well on the social or the governance
side of things so I'd say I get away
with basically the Optics of big tobacco
getting higher uh ESG scores or better
ESG scores than something like a test
well and I don't know if you remember
when Elon was about to take over Twitter
there was this interview and they said
to him well what are your thoughts on
like what's your policy on diversity and
he was like I believe in a flat
meritocracy if you're good you stay if
you're not good you leave right that's
how every company in the world should be
run okay and that is an nothing much of
these people to them
they freak out when they hear that right
because they're anti-merit this is my
point right they don't want the company
to be as successful as possible they
want to take all their social justice
boxes because that's what they believe
in ideology
yeah and why does it only work in like
board seats and stuff like that so why
why aren't women fighting or to be more
on construction sites and on deep sea
fishermen the hardest jobs in the world
it's like why aren't more women fighting
to do that it's because those people are
there for the meritocracy right there
like remember when people were up in
arms I think it was United where they
basically said uh we're we're hiring
uh all moving forward 50 of Pilots are
going to be women okay 50 of pilots and
they were like yeah but ninety percent
of the applicants are men yeah so it's
like if I'm me and I just want to get to
where I'm going from New York to Miami
bro I don't care if you're black white
yellow Puerto Rican Haitian Jamaican I
don't give a [__] get me from point A to
point B yeah I don't need being like
well did you check off the diversity box
no in order for the job get me the pilot
who's gonna get me there safely yeah not
person checking the Dei ESG OPP score
well but I don't know if you can find
this story in the UK we had the
situation in the Royal Air Force where
they they had a diversity Drive they
decided to recruit a certain number and
then they basically said we're not
hiring any more useless white men oh God
right and then they just couldn't get
any [__] Pilots
people were like that's right 160 white
men did they actually sued the
government and and got paid out because
they were being discriminated against
because in the air the Air Force these
are the guys that dropped bombs on our
enemies I don't care who they sleep with
sleepwear is I just care that they're
good at dropping bombs can we just get
some guys who can do that yeah you know
what I mean it I mean what are we doing
again common sense is going to Prevail
guys because more and more people from
all sides are going to sit there who are
Democrats who are Republicans who are
whoever they're going to say yeah you
know what I don't know man I'm just not
I can't see this thing making any sense
you know what I'm done I'm done with
this there's going to be more and more
of that happen you know what Patrick I
agree with you and I think a we got to
be optimistic but more there's actual
evidence for this so I get invited to
speak at different places including
corporate you know situations right and
they're all very scared to hear from me
about this because I show them this [__]
and I'm like this is what's going on and
they know it from the inside anyway and
the very few of them will say anything
publicly
privately they all agree they all know
they all know this the corporate people
the people who are running things
they've been bullied into this they're
afraid to speak up right we just got to
give them permission to do that by
seeing that it's not just the crazies
who are making these points there's some
reasonable people who want people of all
Races to to never be discriminated
against who want people to get along
right that's what I want I just want you
if you're good you get the job if you're
not good you don't get the job you hit
the nail on the head about people
basically being afraid to speak what's
on their mind so I do a show where I
interview women on the street right okay
about not prostitutes
sometimes they are we're not
discriminating over here
don't care how they identify but I asked
them a series of questions okay what are
you looking for in a man what are you
bringing to the table why would you be
an ideal wife by the way do you think
men should participate in women's sports
and that's the one question that either
triggers them or basically they're like
listen I don't really want to answer
this uh not what's your body count not
you know what makes you a good wife it
should men be competing in sports and
that's this that's the question like oh
uh yeah well I think that you know and
they'll give some sort of PC answer or
they'll say an answer and then the
interview's over I'll say hey thank you
for the interview is it okay if we use
this on and they'll say yeah but the one
part about the women's sports can we
maybe not use that or you know I don't
like what I said or by the way you know
I would have said something a little bit
different but you know I have a job so
it's like that is the one trigger point
so sometimes it takes getting out on
these streets talking to these people
that's the one thing that they won't
basically get behind on camera they
which what you're talking about now is
we're living in an age where social
media and mainstream media are divisions
in the army of the left that will come
and attack you these didn't used to
exist
um a very good friend of mine
um passed away recently he was quite old
but he was the exco ex president of La
Coke which is the largest Coke bottler
in America in the late 80s a gentleman
named Jesse Jackson and his organization
called rainbow push do you remember this
went into their offices when they were
basically based outside of Los Angeles
and a very Hispanic area called at that
time it was Riverside so out there in
Riverside very diverse area
and that's where La Coke had a
tremendous amount of employees and a
large bottling
Jesse Jackson's people wheel in they
asked for a meeting come to the
conference room and they asked for a
quarter million dollars to be their
consultant because they need to get to
and they put this number out it was like
25 or 30 percent
African Americans in management and
you're obviously discriminatory because
of that and they said can you come back
next week Harold was a smart guy
um brought him back next week and says
okay we need to do a press release
together because we're going to lay off
uh 17 I think it was almost 17
Hispanic people that are in management
jobs as well as the following and then
we're going to announce that we're doing
this and we'd like you to be at the
press conference when we announced this
that you've come in here you can be your
consultant and these people are going to
be laid off and reconstitute this
racially toward your your target here
when they said that guess who left
Jesse wanted no part of that press
release no part of that Pros well they
bluffed him so they bluffed him right
out but they didn't have the mainstream
media they didn't have social media so
this has been going on for a while it
was a Shakedown and there was a book
eventually written about this simply
called Shakedown where there's money in
this people are going for the money that
are not true believers and so we also
have with all the things that are going
on here and the liberal media and social
media coming out there that the people
you're talking about that will say
things in private are scared to death of
the of the Public Public backlash that
happens from the other side and that's
what people are running from now they're
running from that and and you have to be
able to stand up to it and you have to
stand up to it and say it's hard to do
today so hard if you've got a job above
you yeah yeah if you've got people above
you yeah if you're working for and like
it this can be a weird advice I'm gonna
give this is the worst time ever to for
Fortune 500 company ever this is the
worst time to work for a company that is
on the stock market that is asking money
from
Vanguard State Street and what do you
call it uh Vanguard Black Rock yeah
black garden because
you have to you have to abide by certain
rules and guide guidelines or else
you're being silenced the employees
being silenced you're afraid to say like
you know he got banned on Instagram okay
for what for Adam Adam's not a guy
that's gonna go out there and say stuff
to get banned if there's anybody that is
not a guy that should give a he gets
panned okay guess what is he going to
get his account back 100 is going to get
his account back is it going to take a
week two weeks three weeks a month two
months ago of course if you work at
Instagram and you follow the content
reach out we're already dealing with a
couple but if you do DM me if you work
at Instagram or send us an email info
valuetainment.com and put Adam insta and
we'd love to follow up with you because
we got some guys on the inside that's
working on it but anybody but here's the
part you're gonna end up getting your
account back why am I confident he's
going to get his account back we have
eyeballs we have distribution we have
audience we have leverage we have we
have ways that we're going to get you're
going to see his good accounts Gonna
Come Back
but how many people who don't have that
who have 1300 followers 1800 followers 2
000 followers there is no Instagram
customer service line no what are they
going to do by Design
those are the guys that are afraid who
don't want to post anything they're
worried because if somebody takes them
down they don't have that help to get
somebody to get their account back those
guys are not protected so no I I think
it's a it's a time where the the people
that want to get like a guy calls me
again this is another guy this is an
athlete you know who he is he calls me
he says I'm not happy about what's going
on we have a conversation together
that's okay so what do you want to do he
says well I'm getting all these other
offers and monies are coming in from
sponsorship I mean just staying quiet
but I can't stand the fact that I'm
doing this and I said how much I said do
you have the kind of money where you
don't give a [__] if you get any more
monies as I do so I said so what do you
want but I want to get more money I said
do you have other ways of making money
without having to rely on the machine
not yet
what do you tell this guy
build you've got to build your own thing
yeah so so it's either go talk go a line
to get backing go somewhere that they're
gonna deflect for example Rogan has a
reached Saint status we have very good
we have one of our best exchangers him
and I yesterday best ever and and he's a
guy that I think he is a the most
necessary voice that's causing these
types of conversations and we got his
back I mean this is a guy that's you
know you're you're a fighting Authority
and you're questioning Authority guess
what we defend your ability to question
authority and see what's right and
what's wrong we're going to defend that
but Rogan's got Saint status right he's
UFC Dana White Endeavor all those guys
and and you know what they know what
brand is here's what Dana White's brand
is can you imagine if Endeavor calls
Dana White and say Dana you got to kind
of take it easy with this what do you
think Dana's going to say
what are you talking about right but
because that's how he's
created his brand from day one and they
said well there can be no sports in
America and UFC cannot have any fights
for two years hell no we're going to
freaking Dubai yeah we're going to Abu
Dhabi what yes and the only sport that
was playing at the time was what
UFC guess what we watch we watch UFC
instead of basketball you know fans
cardboarded face you're watching a
football game saying what the hell is
this show the weakness so meaning Dana's
brand is say something right hey look at
Dana he hit his wife I did and I'm
embarrassed by it and I have to live
with us for the rest of my life and the
more people that I'm most embarrassed
with is my kids do you realize I have to
face this for you nobody here is going
through harder times
so the brand of Dana's like I don't give
a sh so this is like for the small guy
who's working at a Fortune 500 SMP file
this is why Patrick
there's more responsibility for people
who do have a voice and for people who
do have a platform to actually step up
that's why because because they can 100
agree and and so we've had you know
videos taken down on YouTube we kick up
a fuss in the Press because we can boom
comes back we had a bank account shut
down a few weeks ago uh we don't know if
it was political or not but again big
stink everywhere online we get it back
what if you're an ordinary person yeah
so that's why people who do have a
platform your athlete friend like if
you've got enough money you gotta you've
got to speak up and if you don't yet you
don't have that Independence and build
it go out and actually get yourself to a
point where you can speak because it's
important right like if you feel so bad
doing what you're doing no millions are
going to make you feel better about it
you know you know you know it's crazy
though you know what I tell these guys
they call me and they tell me the fear
of losing everything I said listen you
know
Ali wasn't afraid he stood up
X y's he wasn't afraid a lot of these
guys weren't afraid what happened what
kind of a guy do you want to be known
for do you just want to be known as a
guy that made a half a billion dollars
or do you want to be known as a guy that
your kids want to gonna look back and
say my dad took a stand and he was not
afraid to stand up and voice his opinion
you got money that's right you got
plenty money what do you so well yeah no
I I understand what you're saying but
again this is it's it's it's so easy to
talk hard and you are
but that guy has to make the decision
and there is a fear of making that
decision and there's a lot of things you
lose when you make that decision but
there's something you get too you get
something which is younger you you know
yourself as a real man in that moment
well look at the at the end for longest
time I create I was creating content
people would say Pat you know Patrick's
talking politics my team's about to lose
now I've seen this before it's the
mistake pbd is making he's officially
talking politics he's about to lose his
entrepreneurship audience
I sat there I'm like
you know
I don't do well with control
I don't do well with authority you yeah
no I listen more hey Mario don't let me
talk politics and I'm talking politics
finally I'm like listen man here's what
we're gonna do we have entertainment
business all the stuff that we're doing
great we have pbd podcasts we're talking
freely about all the issues and I just
want to talk to people about real issues
in life that's going on let's talk shop
and you agree disagree I'm going to be
challenged oh you were wrong [__] I was
wrong I was like you were wrong we were
both right and wrong okay great let's go
research this but what it's doing is
this the evolution of the audience grown
with us is saying I'm also kind of going
through the Journey with you guys right
but at the end of the day the problem is
going to be by those of us that can
actually have a voice and we can push
back and we don't because we're worried
about losing a sponsor hey those guys
going to give us money what about this
we don't need any sponsors we've had a
lot of weird sponsors come in we have
multiple alcohol people that will come
and tell me we'll pay you you know
million dollars two million dollars
three million dollars elected I'm the
worst sponsor to do alcohol okay I I
drink old-fashioned once a month yeah
and I want you to take a picture every
time I drink an old-fashioned from the
moment they bring it to me to the moment
I finish drinking it it goes from this
much to how much uh Adam you see it
every time yeah I usually finish it
so but the point I'm like I can't do
that man hey coffee you guys want to do
coffee sponsorship we can't do that but
I agree with you we ought to be a little
louder I want to go to the story I'll
let you wrap up and then I want to go to
the story with what's going on with
California parents who don't affirm
gender Yeah well yeah just to Circle
back you brought up the fact that my
Instagram account was taken and uh I
really empathize with everything that's
going on with Tate because they don't
give you a warning
there was no hey this is the reason why
there was no hay in order to contest
this uh press this button it's just gone
man and I can't tell you how it feels as
something that's worked I only had a
hundred thousand uh followers on
Instagram but I've had it for 10 years
I've worked my ass off started doing
basic money tip stuff all the way to 10
years later now I'm doing interviews
with pbd and Andrew Tate like the the
progression it feels like someone comes
in your house
robs everything takes it over locks the
door and you have no ability to
basically say hey what's going on here
guys it's like a raping of the highest
kind and it's ultimately what I've
learned from doing this show is the the
first amendment in America here in
America
is the greatest thing we have and if
you're if you silence someone and if you
muzzle someone and you can't say what's
on your mind I'm not a crazy person I'm
not a far-right conspiracy theorist not
far less I'm kind of like you
Constantine I'm very very much in the
middle very much and you know what's the
famous Voltaire quote like I disagree
with what you're saying but I will
defend vehemently your right to say it
that's how I feel right now and it's a
very weird thing and last thing you know
the famous quote like the first the
famous poem first they came for the
hungarians and then I was in hungarians
and I give them they came for the the
labor union and I wasn't a labor unit so
then I didn't say anything then they
came for the Jews and I wasn't Jewish I
didn't say anything it's like then they
came for me and there's no one left to
say anything and that's how I feel it
was like yeah during the January 6th
stuff I was like yeah I don't know
that's not my thing during the covet
thing yeah thing it's like no no now
that it's happened to me it's like holy
[__] here it's like if they'll get you
they can go for anybody at any given
point for any reason you're gonna get
your account back
it's the hundreds of thousands of people
that will never get their accounts back
from which is sad which is sad those are
the people that will never get their
accounts back because they don't have a
voice or backing together accounts and
that's a very sad thing I love your
confidence I'm gonna get my account I'm
telling you right now you're gonna get
your account back there is no question
about it but it's going to take a minute
until we there's a fast strategy or slow
strategy the fast strategy is tomorrow
you come out and tell people that you're
transgender yeah I'll do it right
I love what Constantine said in that
speech can you pull up the speech on him
and his wife getting pregnant 15 months
ago of course this is a while back but
yeah please press that watch this part
that's my favorite part of speech go
ahead 15 months ago my wife got pregnant
not me because we're old school
[Laughter]
by the way what's the environment here
what's the essentially Oxford is like a
Harvard yeah right and this is a they're
debating Society they've had former U.S
presidents Prime Ministers all of that
come here and they asked me to speak at
a debate about has World culture gone
too far and to be honest with you I'm
kind of getting tired of talking about
wokeness because I'm just like we need
to get through that to the post-work
conversation because anti-woke and woke
to me are both like pretty crazy right
now you know what I mean we could we
just got to get through it uh so I I
talked about that but from a different
angle it you know you heard it earlier
talking about climate change and so on
and just saying you're not being
effective and my friend Melissa Chen I
don't know if you guys know her she
tweeted something a long time ago that
really stuck with me she said you cannot
stay woke if you build anything whether
that's muscle whether that's a business
and whatever because one once you start
getting into the real world and you
start trying to do things you understand
it's not all black and white there's
trade-offs you go this way you're going
to lose this you go this way you're
going to lose that right and it shows
you a little bit of the Nuance of
reality uh and it forces you to confront
the world as actually so Melissa Chan is
great yeah I love the part about you you
talking with John Anderson about you
know Thomas sold there's no such thing
as Solutions but trade-offs that whole
concept you were going back and forth
with Thomas so a legendary mind and
something else yeah hey if you enjoyed
this short clip you want to watch the
whole thing click over here but if you
want to make 2023 the beginning of the
greatest years of your life I host a
conference once year it's called The
Vault conference where 3 000 CEOs
executive entrepreneurs from around the
world come together to strategize for
three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will
guidera the guy that ran 11 Madison in
New York if you run a business if you're
a CEO entrepreneur and executive this is
not an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]